what about uh just in general becoming
detached from possessions
like minimalism
and uh not having many things
so the the capitalist world
kind
of pushes you towards having possessions
and
deriving joy from more and more and
better possessions
have you
have you returned back to the joys of
that world
or do you find yourself
enjoying
the minimalist life
uh a little of both i think i
really don't like i find things to be a
burden to be a massive burden
yeah and
and to me when you have burden like that
you know even if it's just knowing that
there's like boxes in your basement of
stuff you know whatever it might be
it makes it hard to
focus
um and so
i personally like i mean my ideal like
if i had a my house for example would be
to have like nothing on anything it just
and and
that to me is like peaceful some people
find that to be not peaceful
for me it's like i love the night to
have the night the idea that
if needed i could like pack up and move
yeah and not worry about anything do i
actually have that in reality
no
um we're about to have a baby
you know there's but it's like it's our
i already see it it's like stressful
there's like boxes of stuff showing up
at the house like bottles and
clothes and
all these little hats and whatnot and
i do i do have to like sometimes go into
my meditation to just
just say like this is okay you know
like it's it's okay to have all of this
stuff
it's not permanent you know and um but i
do think that it's easy to get lost in
it all
and it's important to remember given all
that like people who buy houses
you know buy a home and buy a house and
make a home out of it and you start a
family it's easy to
forget that even though you have all
these responsibilities you're still free
and like freedom takes work and it takes
remembering it takes meditation on it
but you're you're free
you're you're born free you live free i
mean depends of course which country but
in the united states even with all the
possessions
even with all the burdens
um
sort of credit and owning money and all
those kinds of things
you can
scale everything down and you're free
but ultimately the people you love
if you love each other it doesn't take
much money to be happy together
and for me i i personally value that
freedom of
having the freedom to always pursue your
happiness as opposed to being burdened
by material possessions
that uh
you know yeah that basically limit your
ability to be happy because you're
always paying off stuff you're always
catching you know trying to match the
neighbors that are always a little bit
richer that kind of pursuit i think that
pursuit is wonderful for innovation and
for building cooler better things
but on an individual level
i think you have to remember that first
of all life is finite and second of all
like your goal is not to get a bigger
house your goal is to be just content
and happy
right in the moment i completely
completely agree with them
you